I was still so young and I remember
Megan Fox got spray tanned and I wasn't
allowed to get spray tan Lindsay Lohan
makes a co-star confession she was
jealous of Megan Fox I was really upset
about that nearly 20 years after
starring together in Confessions of a
Teenage Drama Queen I'm Lola stepp I
didn't know her home had a name is that
supposed to be that famous New York
sense of humor Lilo admits she was a
little annoyed with certain things Meg
got to do that she didn't I remember
Megan Fox got spray tanned and I wasn't
allowed to get spray tan I was really
upset about that it's all revealed as
part of Lindsay's Cosmo cover story Lola
was so fun to play because she was just
so passionate and such a nerd when it
came to like the things that she cared
about and I was still so young we were
both 17 so it's like we're gonna have
things that make us drama queens and if
we don't that'd be kind of sad because
we'd be missing out on a lot
so you know we're just having to rage
most of the time Megan played mean girl
Carla to Lindsay's Lola I'll show you
what it's like to be in my school is
that a threat absolutely I am pretty
mean I'm a typical bad girl uh but you
know it's fun playing those roles
because I like to think that I'm not
actually like that in real life so I had
a good time but it could have been a
better time at least according to Lin's
if she'd gotten to do what she wanted to
do with her character's look remember
Megan Fox got spray tanned and I wasn't
allowed to get spray tan I was really
upset about that but that's not the only
thing Lin's wanted and I wanted my hair
to be blonder for the character but they
wanted it to be more red so I was like
trying to find a way that I could bleach
it myself without them noticing which I
did and then they noticed well despite
the lack of spray tan and bleached hair
there's no doubt the movie's a modern
day Disney classic
[Music]
so I got the script and I read the part
of Lola and I just fell in love with her
she's basically
every teenage girl but more so I thought
it was just something really fun to do
and when I got the script I was hoping
that they'd like me for it and we met
and everyone all of us got along really
well there are no small parts only small
actors
you can quote me
foreign
[Music]
theatrical she's really different from
me the um she's very into fashion though
which is how I am and she's kind of
different she likes to kind of do her
own thing she doesn't really worry about
what others are thinking which I think
is really cool she's very independent in
her own sense which is awesome which
more girls should be like it is a girl
Power movie there's a lot of stuff
that's um that works out on the girl's
end I think that it kind of shows girls
to be themselves and not worry about
what others think and just do their
thing and good things will come with
time
foreign